the only thing better than data is Big
Data
but getting your hands on large datasets
is no easy feat from unwieldy storage
options to difficulty getting analytics
tools to run over your data set properly
large data sets can lead to all sorts of
struggles when it comes to actually
doing something useful with them so
what's a data scientist to do stay tuned
to find out welcome to AI adventures
where we explore the art science and
tools of machine learning my name is Yu
Feng Guo and on this episode we're gonna
check out the bigquery public data sets
and explore the amazing world of open
data we all love data preferably the
more the merrier
but as file sizes grow and complexity
increases it becomes increasingly
challenging to make practical use of
that data
bigquery public data sets our data sets
that Google bigquery hosts for you to
access and integrate into your
applications so this means that Google
pays for the storage of these data sets
and provides public access to the data
via your cloud project you pay only for
the queries that you perform on the data
moreover there's a one terabyte per
month free tier making getting started
super easy looking at the public data
sets page we can see that at the time of
this recording there are nearly 40
public data sets each data set in turn
has Mining's tables thousands of queries
from hundreds of projects all of the
world are already making use of these
vast public data sets what's really neat
though is that each of these data sets
comes with a bit of explanatory text
that helps you get started with querying
the data and understanding its structure
let's take a look at an example here's
the New York City tree census the page
shows us how we can easily find the
answers to questions like what are the
most common tree species in New York
City and how had the tree species
changed since 1995 in New York City
these are all accessible by literally
one click from the docs page
which opens right into the bigquery
interface another data set that is quite
amazing is the open images data set
it contains approximately 9 million URLs
along with metadata for images that have
been annotated with labels spanning over
6,000 categories using it you can find
answers to your most pressing questions
about images on the web like how many
images of a trolley bus are in this data
set so over 3,000 but I digress
bigquery open datasets is a great way to
explore public datasets and practice
your data analysis skills combined with
tools that we've looked at before like
data lab facets and tensorflow
you could really come up with some
awesome data size so what are you
waiting for head on over to the public
datasets page and let your analysis run
wild for more details and examples
check out the expanded blog post i've
linked to down below in the description
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud AI adventures and if you enjoyed
it please like it and consider
subscribing to get all the latest
episodes right when they come out for
now check out bigquery's public datasets
and start clearing away